have happened with this this colloquium
is that it features you know many of the
speakers sort of have this um
have this um
uh you know theme of bridging between
between physics and computer science and
hence is a great example of this so he's
uh he's a condensed matter theorist but
his work has been really um you know
um in a lot of his work which I really
appreciate has been bridging between
Concepts from computer science and
physics and condensed metaphysics so
he's done done work on area laws and uh
um you know the complexity of of ground
and low energy states is is uh he's
worked on
verification of quantitness
and in this talk which is uh it seems
very exciting is he's going to talk
about actual Quantum circuit complexity
and how to how to get at it through
pretty novel uh novel uh tools so Jen's
looking forward to your your good
looking
yeah that's great um thanks so much
indeed you're too kind thanks to Umesh
for this um invitation to this wonderful
um seminar series on Bridging the fields
as you say between physics and um
computer science
I would have loved to be there in flesh
and blood and in person but now it's
great to be here at least um virtually
so in this talk as Umesh has said we
will be concerned with Quantum circuit
complexity or rather the linear growth
thereof now with complexity of course we
are very much at home yeah at Simon's
and even though the the flavor we have
in mind is not not quite that of
computational complexity it's truly very
much um related and before I get started
I should give ample credit to these
wonderful people here I had I've had the
pleasure to work with this on this work
and I think at least one of these people
or two of them actually should be also
in the in the panel emulator today or
later this evening on myself
so in a way
um we will go on a journey
um when we Meander through the theme
that is somewhere
well bridging gaps it's kind of
somewhere located at the intersection of
high energy physics holography and the
Wormhole growth Paradox
um then uh Quantum Computing and
statistical physics and thermodynamics
in in one way or the other even though
it's kind of probably fair to say that
we are sitting somewhere and here in
this talk so we will be mostly inspired
by ideas of quantum Computing and
Quantum information methods and hint
um to the other aspects um mentioned now
there will be two concepts that will
guide us through this talk these are
Notions of circuit and state complexity
now the highest level complexity can be
seen as a as a tool as a means to make
sense of the enormative pilot space in
quantum mechanics now pivot space is Big
it's it's huge and notice of complexity
can be seen as a guide in in this game
someone often reads statements about
quantum computers operating in
exponentially large Hilbert spaces and
this being the origin of the
computational speed up over classical
computers and why there's not entirely
wrong in a way one has to appreciate
that the set of states that can be
prepared efficiently on a quantum
computer is an exponentially small
subset of robot space so there's been
works on the convenient illusion of
Hilbert space and and there's a point to
it as one one cannot access the entire
Vector space efficiently of course we
can think of an of an onion picture of
like more and more complex States we can
reach with the least complex States I'm
sitting there in the center of the onion
good but maybe it's a good moment to to
become a little bit
um more concrete So In classical
Computing I don't need to to teach you
so the second complexity of a
computation captures the the number of
Elementary steps that's minimally uh
needed to determine
um an outcome so that the complexity of
Boolean function would be the the
minimum number of basic of Elementary
steps that's needed to evaluate the
function so the the precise fine print
will depend on the on the border chosen
sure but this notion of complexity
provides a useful way to to quantify the
hardness of a computational problem
because the the number of steps um
scales with the with the size of the
input so the problem has a rather weak
dependence on on the specific Choice
um of the model
and then
um the computational tasks can be
considered uh feasible or or easy if
it's complexities grows no faster than
the power of the input size and would be
intractable otherwise as one says or I'm
computationally so the the complexity
separates computational tasks into easy
and hard ones
so a reading of the famous treasury
these states that all reasonable models
of computation give rise to the same
class of easy problems that are
computable in polynomial time a
statement that presumably also applies
to natural processes that are occurring
in in nature
so our last of us our oddly
about this quantum
um and similar Notions of Quantum
circuit complexities take over
immediately from the classical to the
quantum wall they are motivated and
pretty much precisely the same fashion
but there's also some Physics C points
um coming in
um
say when thinking of like Quantum phases
of matter where one would allow con the
quantum circuits when going from one
point in a phase to another while
keeping the the hamiltonian Gap Gap open
so yes the key definition that's in the
center of all this so that's the second
complexity as the least number of two
qubit gates from a given gate set that
is needed to represent a given unitary
so we have a given unitary we want to
think about it in terms of
um
Gates
how many of them do we need here in the
um traditional exact setting and I will
say something about the approximate
setting
um later and the state complexity can be
seen as the immediate State analog as
the least number of two qubit gates to
create a given pure state from a
fiducial
um Quantum State say the the all zero
state
so this definition makes a lot of sense
it's very natural it's um it's it's very
meaningful and and so on it also helps
to
um to to to capture uh things alas it's
notoriously hard to to compute and
that's not a surprise
um so clearly uh we could be doing
something with a Quantum circuit It
prepares States but maybe we should like
undo things in later steps to then have
a state that allows us to to better
prepare another state there's all kinds
of dependencies so
um
it's it's no surprise that this is um a
a computationally
um hard problem so maybe a a more
quantitative way of of putting this
related to a kind of related but not
identical problem is that the the run
time of the best known algorithm for t
count that decides whether the optimal
gate decomposition of a Quantum circuit
that is given us a sequence of Clifford
from the Clifford group that often seen
as kind of relatively easily
implementable that can be done
transversely on the on the surface code
and so on and T Gates which are the the
precious expensive
um extra resource that you need on N
qubits involves fewer than or equal to
empty Gates or more is
um has a kind of uh uh a runtime that
scales exponential in the in the system
size and um similar questions are
related to Circuit lower bonds so it's a
not very surprising that the
computationally hard task to
um identify the second complexity that's
that again it's like very meaningful and
in many ways so you can see like the
circuit or state complexity as a as a
tool to kind of organize unitaries and
Quantum States and in kind of diagrams
that kind of label States and in
unitaries according to their complexity
say on on the left side on on the state
level would be like product States it
can be prepared with
um unit depths Quantum circuits there is
like Matrix products they can be
prepared with
um staircase circuits of Step n g is
that states also of this type there's
um multi-scale redomatization that would
be uh a n log n
um complexity and and so on
on the unitary side we can think of like
circuits for classical Shadows which are
on the on the shallow side there is the
Asian Quantum circuits for Quantum
approximate optimization unitary K
designs we come to later
polynomial random circuits that snake
has worked so much on and on the on the
right hand side we would have have like
high random circuits but that are really
costly to to spell out an approximate
well in terms of of quantum circuits so
again
circuit and state complexity is a very
natural and meaningful and make a lot of
sense they catalog States and so on they
relate to notice of computational
complexity but they are notoriously
article view they are kind of
um the the best known the runtime of the
personal algorithms would scale
exponential in the systems right so it's
when you kind of want to think of how
um complexity scale say for a family of
circuits it seems completely
inconceivable even for a small number of
qubits to make a plot or something how
the the complexity would scale say for a
meaningful
um instance of of a meaningful family of
of quantum circuits I mean even for a
tiny number of qubits is completely out
of scope to see what scaling what it
would have in in the complexity in this
sense
alas this is precisely what we will do
in the next part of of this talk when we
have a look at how
the complexity grows for so-called
random Quantum circuits
now
of course
Quantum information they are everywhere
in so many forms and and flavors most
prominently maybe they feature strongly
in the recent efforts of the motivated
by work by Scots on like Quantum
advantages of having like some like
random circuit implemented followed by
measurements and there's some strong
arguments that one cannot sample
classically efficiently from a
distribution that's nearby the output
distribution of such a random Quantum
circuit followed by by measurements but
they also feature in in many other
settings what's most important here is
maybe the idea that they can be largely
seen as proxies for for the real thing
for Quantum keratoconomics generated by
time dependent or time independent
um complex Quantum chaotic hamiltonian
say from the contents matter or high
energy realm and why it is not quite the
same thing in the many of the results
carry over and people have looked at say
look organization Properties or
properties of time out of time or
correlation functions for random
circuits that very much mimic the real
thing of the hamiltonian Dynamics which
goes as far as some people like almost
using random circuits as almost the same
thing as the the true hamiltonian
Dynamics in a way but it can be studied
in a in an easier and more natural
um
fashion
so in what for us we will largely see
these random circuits as
like toy proxies of
intricate complex
um chaotic Dynamics so there's many um
hi Scott there's many like forms and
flavors once again so um prominent in
this talk with the bricklayer circuits
of the layouts um here but we can also
think of lots of other
um structures of say um staircase
circuits where in one run you would
create a so-called matrix product State
out of that in MPS a mini paper state
but if you do many runs of this
staircase you would get like some
like certain flavor of a random Circle
if you pick harun and state our random
circuits and rnf Gates and place them
but you can also think of a random
random circuit where you pick a random
layout and um you pick how random
Quantum Gates and you place according to
this random layout or arguments are
enough to capture any of these of these
settings so the way we kind of make
sense of a circuit depth would be that
we put these circuits in chunks so that
they would include a backward
um causal cone and these guys would be
called cause of slice if not so
important so we would kind of
um count the depth of the circuit by the
number of
um causal slices we would put next to
each other and think of the of the
setting as
um being like a bricklayer circuit where
we pick
um how random two cubic Gates place them
there and then we look at the family of
circuits that we get by having deeper
and deeper circuits of this of this kind
so
so how does the complexity grow so how
does this complexity grow as a function
of the depth of the circuit if you make
this deeper and deeper what happens to
the Circuit complexity in a way we've
just um defined
now of course every circle is its own
description so the heart of the matter
is like how much we can compress this
circuit and whether there's some sort of
redundancy
um in the circuit there could be a
significantly shorter description of the
same unit area that is generated by the
random circuit at hand so the heart of
the matter is if you make the circuit
deeper and deeper how would the second
complexity Define in the way a minute
ago would grow with the size of of the
circuit now this question has moved
quite a bit into prominence integral
visibility in in in the Quant
information realm and also in the high
energy realm mostly
um because of a kind of a a context that
was made Popular by these gentlemen here
by Brown and suskin in particular the
the the rights person shown here that's
a very prominent figure one of the
co-inventors of of string theory use
kind of
um taught the world with the question of
the complexity growth in the holographic
context and specifically the complexity
growth of thermofry quantum doubles
where he um gives like very uh like
flamboyant and inspiring talks on that
matter John Prescott is is quoted to
saying that um whatever it is uh Lenny
suskin has the beautiful ability to um
very nicely explain what it's about so
um
the the the context that's
um Lenny has and put this question in is
that of the complexity growth of thumb
if you doubles these are quantum states
with a property that the reduction to
every part would be um Gibson would be
thermal States
and um in the setting of holography that
relates to different physical theories
maybe that of Einstein gravity in onto
this is a space and Quantum
um 50 was sitting on the on the boundary
so this context of holography term a few
doubles uh C is being dual to Eternal
black holes
in this um like negative curve under
this space and the the the black holes
geometry consists of of two sides that
are connected by a by a wormhole so an
Einstein um Frozen bridge and the the
Einsteins the the Vermont's volume is is
start to grow for a time that's
exponential in the number of degrees of
freedom and in the boundary Theory and
as as we just said the the random
Quantum circuit I expect it to be like a
proxy to capture the presumed
hamiltonian actual Dynamics behind the
Horizon so and if that's the case if
they do the the growth of the wellmost
volume is is conject to to match the the
growth of the boundary States complexity
so that what's the the volume growth on
the on the on the gravity side will be
the the complexity growth on the on the
on the on on the quantum side so both
would be expected to reach a value
that's exponentially large in the number
of degrees of freedom but at the at a
very long long time this is kind of
weird it came from that the the
complexity should grow it's not it's
like that's the the right Quantum
property that we should look at the
complexity should grow
um linearly in time until until a long
time so the specific statement is that
one would
um expect and that's kind of this
problem is asking conjecture that I
would expect a linear growth
um of the depth of the circuit until a
time that's exponential in the depth of
the second
and
um
if you think about that this is
not such an unnatural Behavior it's
actually pretty it's pretty natural
out of the matter so
um so think of the random circuit as a
random walk in a in in Herbert space in
Herbert space is Big so so how unlucky
can you be that you would kind of go
back in this in in this random Circle
you will always kind of conquer a new
territory along the way so only at a
time when you basically sampled out this
entire helmet space you will kind of get
back and would get cancellations along
the way and then the kind of complexity
would kind of saturate to a a constant
constant value so the the upshot is that
there will be few cancellations and for
most of the time until very late times
when when kind of cancellations what
what kind of set it so again this would
mean that cancellations actually hardly
matter they you know and and it's kind
of natural to expect this kind of linear
course Behavior
so yes that's
very natural and that's also a nice pack
of the envelope calculation that Lenny
has done
um
but
um
but how would one judge I mean there
will be cancellations so that's um it's
not that there's not a shorter
descriptions possibly so there will be
cancellations there will be um show the
quantum circuits but we just expect this
to be not dominant for most of most
circuits uh and so on so
there's no way we can compute this
property it's not it's a computational
problem so how can we ever see the
complexity grow going as a function of
the depth of the circuit if you can't
compute this quantity and if there will
be consolations there would be something
but
what what can we do so how can the
growth be be judged
so
um
uh 20 minutes into the talk I will keep
it also rather short and then long to
have a bit of time for discussion so I
will not go too much into detail but I
will kind of on a higher level
um say a few things on on how this
argument goes so
as I mentioned complex is too much of a
beast type refer to the t-con problem as
a um as a computational problem so let's
um maybe stay away from the complexity
for a while and rather think in terms of
a dimension of a kind that's slightly
easier to to capture and the and the
starting point of this um framework that
we've been thinking about is the notion
of a contraction map that sounds rather
rather fanciful but it what it is it's
just to it's the map from our Quantum
Gates
um two qubit Quantum Gates into the
unitary group of n qubits which just
reflects how we place the quantum gates
in a given architecture so we in one way
or the other will place these Quantum
gates in our architecture and that will
be the choice of the unitary Gates and
the the parts of the gate they will
realize some unitary in this large
dimensional
um uh like Sub in this as a subset in
this large um group
and there will be a reachable set which
would be the the unit test we can reach
by changing the parameters of the
unitaries there's actually a very
strange set it's hard to capture is not
a manifold it's very fingery and funny
it's a set
and that will have a dimension and that
we call the accessible dimension of the
set
now
what is important
is
that this image U of A the set is not a
manifold
um but it's what it's called a semi-adge
robotic set
what is this so an algebraic set is a
set of real vectors which are
constrained by polynomial equalities
and a semi-algebraic set is one that's
constrained is a collection of real
vectors that's constrained by a set of
equalities and inequality constraints
for example uh take the the unit circle
in two dimensions that's not a manifold
but the open disk is a manifold of
Dimension two and the unit circle is a
manifold of Dimension One and this kind
of Dimension would be the the largest
dimension of a foliation in terms of of
manifolds so two would be the dimension
of of of this
now much of the heavy lifting comes from
a principle
um that's actually pretty cool it's the
if the task inside my principle that
says that the image of an arbitrary semi
algebraic set under a polynomial
function is another semiatric bar except
now where does this come in but the
point is it shows that our set U of A
the the unit test at the end of the day
are semi-ager bike set because in one
way or the other other is the placement
given by some polynomial function and
the knobs at the at the beginning are
constrained by a semi algebraic set so
that means that by by virtue of this
this principle the the U of A is a
semi-algeoperic set
now
um the next step is the the rank of this
contraction map that's important in a
point
now that's the rank of a matrix that
approximates this contraction map
linearly around a certain point
now the next step is to prove that this
contraction map has the same rank
throughout the domain except from
a few funny points so except from a
measures still that
um in all possible of all possible of
all possible points so here's a fanciful
way of of saying that that's the
lowering glucose so the the low rank
Locus or the the
um the set of points of non-maximum rank
is an algebraic set of measure zero and
it's close in the algebraic topology so
equivalently the the set of points
um with maximum rank is an open set of
measure one and this D A that we are
looking for this this rank has the
maximum rank
so that sounds a bit fanciful so why
would that be interesting well it's it's
very interesting because it it puts
things upside down it it helps us so
that we don't have to kind of optimize
over all circuits which we couldn't do
in polynomial time anyway
um or so like optimize things so but we
rather say that in a way
um
almost all circuits would have like this
maximum Rank and we only have to find a
sufficiently generic family of of random
circuits that would have this kind of
linear growth of of of complexity so
it's kind of changing the the
quantifiers of of the problem in a way
so we have to identify an X where R
gross linearly this this
um this this rank grows linearly with r
like with the number of chunks in the
circuits or with the circuit depth if if
you want
and
um
what could be more natural
than picking a Clifford circuit or a
family of random Clifford circuits
yeah so we we have to demonstrate the
point's existence and not optimize over
all settings and we demonstrate this
Point's existence by perturbing
um random Clifford circuits and we do so
by by appending small like infinite
decimal unitaries and kind of counter
the independent directions we can go
into
now this is actually this is the most
tedious part of the of the proof in in
terms of length so we basically take a
like a power basis and expand these
unitaries and this being a Clifford
circuit and we know that the um the
normalizer of the public group is the
um are the Clifford circuit so we can
basically
conjugate the the police to the very end
we can push them to the end and see all
the the powers are being changed by
pushing them through so we can see we
can
count independent directions by by
looking at the at the setting of power
at the very end and then we can indeed
make it a counting argument by counting
these independent directions and see how
this R grows linearly how the r grows
with with uh
um depth of the circle and this indeed
grows linearly with the system size
um
so
the the cliff attacks do the job
so we get a lower amount of this
accessible Dimension so if a denotes the
architecture with r being t l gate so L
is the number of of gates in the trunk
and T is the is the number of them so we
assume this architecture consists of
course slices of L Gates each
then the architecture's accessible
Dimension is lower bounded by a quantity
that goes like
um uh R of a l so scales linearly
without which is what what we wanted
um
good and and the rest is elaborate count
it was kind of interesting that
this is a is a rigorous proof
um but it in a way still picks up the
idea of a counting argument by Lenny but
in in an upside down way that in the
very end it's it's a basic elaborate
counting argument that we that we can
put together so in the end one one sees
that if there was a a circuit a prime
that is much shorter it would have like
a much
um um
would have a much smaller complexity
than other number would kind of get into
a contradiction with the earlier state
that most points would have this um this
same um Rank and dimension so almost
every U has a complexity greater than
this greatest possible R Prime and then
um one can finish this argument by
contradiction to see that indeed the
complexity will grow linearly with um
the size of the set I should say that
that was a nice simplification of
argument of this of our last step of
this argument by a paper by by Lee that
came out earlier this year which is a
kind of a a beautiful refinement of our
last step concerning the Clifford
circuit so this is kind of nice to see
that there's a bit of a shortcut at the
very end but otherwise the logistic of
the argument is very similar
so that gives us the desired wanted
argument there is a linear growth of
complexity so if U is a unitary that's
implemented by a random Quantum circuit
in an architecture that's formed by T
which is like r or L cos and slice of L
Gates each these are the chunks
then the unitary circuit complexity is
lower bounded by this quantity here that
has is linear in R it grows linearly in
the depth with a consonant asymptotic
not important and so it will grow
linearly with the complexity it's not a
counting argument it's not not the back
of the envelope calculation but it's a
rigorous argument with unit probability
over the realizations of the random
circuit until the number of Gates goes
to this number here which is exponential
the system's size which is the point
that where the the complexity flattens
and we expect this saturation to happen
the same about holds for the state
complexity again until a time or a depth
if you want that is exponential in the
system size
so there is a linear growth of the
complexity there's an interesting
dependence I should say on
um
on l
uh which is like 1 over L which is kind
of interesting which is the the depth of
the circuit but again for every depth we
will get a linear growth of the
complexity as a function of the second
thing so this is what we see we do see
the the linear growth this is kind of
the brown suscon projector which we have
settled for the exact certain complexity
so there is a linear complexity growth
very nice
um good
30 minutes into the talk
um let's have a bit of an interlude and
um think a bit about approximate Notions
connections to entanglement to unitary
designs and have a bit of a snippet of a
second part but I keep it rather short
then shorter than too long
um so uh we will be a bit sketchier from
from here
so this is nice we were like very happy
with this results so that can be seen as
a fair resolution of this projector
um so it we do show the linear goals
in under pretty General conditions in a
rigorous fashion with kind of this
um tools of semi algebraic geometry
which is a fresh tool in this context
which is a nice and a pretty powerful I
mean kind of tool to do to work with
now what else would we want maybe the
most pressing thing that I would like to
see or that we would like to see is like
how approximate Notions can be can be
realized because after all this is a
well-defined but a very stringent notion
of complexity so we would equally well
think of a of a notion of complexity
that for giving Unity would not want to
um like realize exactly but only
approximately to a constant error in the
the operator Norm which would like make
perfect sense and why some of the
arguments that we have carry over to
some approximate settings there the
tools are not quite powerful enough as
we have them to give to give strong
results in in the sense that we can
really give a kind of concept error in
the in the in the operator Norm which is
really what we want to see here so
that's really something that we are
thinking about quite quite hard these
days
there's something one can say about in a
very baby sense and also making a
connection to the needs and cost and
entanglement so I mean this in this
context people like to think a lot about
this kind of Nielsen cost
um when they think about Notions of
complexity which is basically the idea
to develop a geometric picture of second
complexity and pick a set of operators
say an operator basis or something and
see the circuit as a Time ordered
integral over these operators with a
certain way that's been switched on and
off in a Time dependent fashion where
the cost will be just some integral over
a norm over these these weights say the
L1 Norm is the most common choice in in
in this set
so
entanglement is not complexity as we
know there's a beautiful paper Millennia
about this but X actually for very small
values of of complexities so there's a
lower bound of the complexity in terms
of entanglement
that relates also to beautiful work by
one of our panelists that um I might
mention later there's also the
interesting
um consequence of that that there's
probability distributions that require a
complexity of the order N squared if you
realize them as a circuit followed by
measurements I don't know what to do
with this but there's the connection
between complexity and entanglement in a
meaningful
um
way
also there's a connection to unitary
design so a generation of unitary key
designs at a depth of the order NT would
imply the approximate branches
conjecture which is great but then how
would we Implement a unitary design of
this of this type so how can unitary
designs be implemented in the first
place
so that's a bit of a procrastination
admittedly I I
admitted freely
um Nick is a one of the leaders in the
field of thinking about how to generate
student designs from random Quantum
circuits and I've been thinking about
that quite a bit over the years as well
to remind you a unitary design is a
collection of unitaries a finite
collection of unitaries that mimics the
measure so that you get a t design if
the average of these finite unitaries is
exactly matching the
um averages over the high measure up to
moments of order t and that's also
meaningful approximate Notions um there
in random circuits of the type that
we're discussing to other talk until now
would give rise to unitary designs in
the sense although not quite to that
accuracy for suitably
um short circuits
now
um
random clipboard circuits as you've seen
in a minute ago they give rise to
designs that's well known
they're not quite for designs they
gracefully fail to be four designs as
one says but they are pre-designs the
exact three designs and they can be
uplifted to arbitrary order designs to
by adding two gates along the way of the
type that we also mentioned earlier
so say you have like 10 000 qubits I
wish but never mind and you want to get
a 29 oil design
so if a Clifford Circle you ask how many
key Gates do you need to add
to uplift this
order three design to a 29 over design
and we worked hard on this and the
answer
it's actually a representation
but the answer is actually quite
striking which is you I'd say five or so
tickets a number
that is constant in the system size so
constant number of three gates is
sufficient to uplift a random preferred
circuit to an arbitrary order design
independent of n independent of the
system size
that's pretty weird it's like a this
kind of uh spread of universality this
t-gateness that sits there and it kind
of spreads all over the place and gets
Amplified and goes over the entire
system and lifting up
all the three designs to arbitrate all
the designs independent of it kind of
funny I I found it pretty funny
um so that's a very technical paper
um this will come out any day or maybe
he does come out today in in the
communications of mathematical physics
um this is a very serious title it's a
German Journal you bet that you're
better serious we couldn't refrain from
ourselves from uh calling the paper on
the preprint server Quantum Homeopathy
works because the good medicine of the T
Gates can be Amplified arbitrarily many
times and you still get the the T design
out as a as a treatment never mind
um find it funny or not we got lots of
funny emails that's for sure afterwards
but this kind of technical paper will
come out in an in a minute so
um
that's this so unitary design if you
could work if you had better unitary
designs we could also approach approach
the brown Tuscan question in a fresh way
we should work harder on this
37 minutes
um
so
I will use the remaining few minutes
that I have
on brainstorming a little bit on what
the thermodynamic implications are
whether a resource theory of
uncomplexity can be defined and so on
with questions of an operational nature
in mind so asking like how complexity
can capture what we can do operational
to a system when we are complexity
constrained in Quantum Computing when
realizing uh heat engine of a kind
or so
we have seen this plot earlier
of of a string that kind of arranges
pure Quantum States according to their
complexity with a low complexity State
sitting on the left side and there is
the
conjecture of brown and starskin of a
second law of complexity that would
argue that
um states are only allowed to develop
into states of higher complexity under
their own natural Dynamics
now this reminds us very much of a
another axis that of mixedness of
entropy if you want and the famous for
like familiar second law
coming along with it the second law of
Thermodynamics that's basically saying
that states want to go to to to to
higher entropy if you have a child
you're not very much know what that
means
um basically Guided by the question of
what processes can be performed by a
macroscopic
Observer not so much asking questions
about complexity but what can be done by
a whole microscopic Observer would see
things happening and then we see things
seemingly going to settings of of higher
entropy
so on the complexity side we would ask
say how occupational how computational
resources and can be captured to carry
out a given process and we can think a
bit on how the middle ground would be
like where there's an interplay between
entropy on the one hand and then
complexity Notions on the other at hand
of a most paradigmatic process namely
that of landauer
um Erasure now Orlando Erasure is the
task of resetting a Quantum memory a
collection of systems or resetting a
collection of quantum systems prepared
in some unknown mixed state
and this
resetting will have a price the state
has an entropy this entropy has to go
somewhere we have to dump it we have to
take this entropy and dump it as heat in
the environment that's part responsible
for the heating of our computers that's
lambdaways actually not most of it but a
big chunk of it and this heat that's
being dumped into the environment has to
be compensated by work that we invest in
the in in the system Erasure requires
thermodynamic work and this landau's
principle it states that we need that um
we need to investigate T lock 2 of work
per discarded [ __ ]
in the environment that's prepared at a
temperature
now we can make it a little bit of a
slightly more refined setting of having
like some Quantum states where maybe
some of the registers are known pure
States others are mixed States maybe
there's some correlations and so on
going on in in in in the settings so if
you have to say given we can think of
um like compressing the entropy like to
assume a compression compressing the
entropy the corner the like pure
registers and the entropy sitting there
in the corner assuming that there's no
work cost coming along with this
compression and then we have our nice
qubit setting there and only the the
noisy chunk needs to be uh reset and
then there's a big body of literature on
the resource theoretic um incarnation of
quantum thermodynamics that really very
precisely look at looks at this question
that one finds that the total Workhorse
that needs to be invested the setting in
this kind of visual theoretic framework
would be like KT log T times some
entropic measure of a set that basically
captures the number of qubits that we
really need to
reset using like Atlanta's um
Erasure
so this is like the the work side of
things like the the entropy side of
things but that's also the complexity
side of things
so let's think of a of a pure state
of maybe High complexity maybe
exponential complexity in the in the
number of qubits
and again you would like to reset to a
fiducial State back to the all zero
state
and we can do that by again doing a
Schumacher compression then we kind of
do the computation we basically undo the
computation we uncompute the setting
which we can do let's see you we do use
dagger in a way and we can do so at no
work cost but possibly at a high
complexity if we really unknow this
exponentially deep circuit then well we
have to invest another exponentially
deep circuit to undo the computation
that's at no work cost but at the high
possibly exponential
um complexity cost that's the one
strategy
but there's also the other strategy of
um
of not caring about this being a pure
state or whatever and just resetting the
system using Lambda or Erasure
at little complexity but then adds a at
a work cost of the type that we have
seen earlier so that suggests that there
should be a kind of a trade-off between
work
entropy-related measures on the one hand
and complexity Notions on the other and
that's kind of thinking motivated us to
think more in terms of General tasks of
like processing Quantum information or
thinking of thermodynamic tasks of a
Kind where complexity restrictions come
into play so we could think of an
arbitrary Quantum State row where we
apply some Circuit of a kind to get as
many as we can zero practices out that
needs to be maximized with a rest chunk
that's being reset under the land hour
average and we've been thinking like
what's the maximum number of of zeros we
can get out under the constraint that
there's a that the circuit is at most
argate so under the complexity
constraint of R for the respective
Quantum second and for this we find the
result that the number the optimal
number of of
cubits that we can get out is n minus
and and Tropic quantity that captures
this complexity constraint setting that
has the operational interpretation of
the amount of work that's required to
reset a state for an agent that can do
at most R Gates so it's kind of
complexity constrained in in in in in in
a way
sure
so what is this entropy matter that's a
new quantity the new entropy measure
that's kind of derived from the
hypothesis testing entropy that accounts
for the complexity so this can be
written as such as as written here so
there's a trace queue that the Q is a p
of M element yeah but it's not an
arbitrary pure of an element but it's
one that's constrained in the sense that
it must be realizable with a circuit of
complexity r
and um there's the trays of Q row larger
than ETA and ETA is the role of a
success probability so that would be
like one minus absolute that should be
close to to one ideally you ask like how
mix must row be in in in in in this
quantity this kind of is the quantity
that that captures this task in an
operational fashion so there's many
properties that we have looked at and
they're derived so it's a variant of a
hypothesis testing entropy there's some
properties we can proof say it's
monotonous and R that's that's a good
thing also in in etern in this success
probability and there's a kind of a
couple of intuitive properties this has
for example if you are very
if ours is very small and we are very
much restricted in what we can do this
is
short so then the
um the states we have that can appear
highly mixed because we can't undo the
computation as on this complexity scale
so we have a high land hour cost because
we have to reset something we cannot
undo things
whereas it's monotonous and going down
at a very large R we see that this
really goes to the standard hypothesis
testing entropy where we have no
complexity constraint M whatsoever let's
also call a couple of other properties
we can prove there's other things that
we don't have but by definition that's a
feature not the bug for example it's not
unitary invariant but that's a good
thing because it's a complexity
constrained quantity so clearly it can't
be unitarily variant because well the
unit could be very complex and would be
kind of cheating to allow for arbitrary
unitary deformations of a Kind so we
said oh there's also paper coming at
some point that kind of really
quietly entirely goes through all these
properties of of of this quantity
is also motivated us to think more about
um like a resource Theory and complexity
where the the uncomplexity are like the
scrap paper they're the the precious
resource that you
half or might have in in a computation
where we think of tasks of like
uncomplexity extraction where we disturb
pure qubits from a given Quantum state
in a complexly restricted fashion you
want to get these
pure qubits around and kind of the
converse process of uncomplexed
expenditure that where you start out in
in scrap paper like in uncomplexed
States like in pure States and have some
junk and apply a circuit that's
um constrained like
are complexity constrained where you
want to prepare a state that an agent
cannot string distinguish or
discriminate from the anticipated um
role at hand so that's kind of similar
to like the entanglement cost and the
entitlement of distillation as we know
it from a timer Theory here kind of
um formulated in terms of a resource
field of uncomplexity and
um have been motivated by how we can see
uncomplexed States as a resource for
computational tasks and we set out in a
way to tackle the question whether yet
another brown sauce can conjecture can
be shown namely whether a resource the
uncomplexity can be formulated and yeah
the answer seems yes it seems so
so that's governed by the complexity
entropy and both tasks are kind of
defined in their optimal probability of
success in the in the in a resource
theoretical framework in terms of the
um entropy measure that I've just shown
a minute ago so we can think of a of a
recent complexity we can also Define
monotones that would grow so one can
also relate this to this kind of second
law of complexity growth that I have
mentioned
good idea
good 50 minutes into the talk and I
promise to be short so that's a maybe a
good moment to to keep the promise so
it's a good moment to to wrap up so this
I'm showing you so um some of the slides
I
um kind of modified and and took from a
slide I gave earlier this year at CERN
where there was a crowd that was
interested in black holes and it was
kind of cute to see that my daughter in
in second grade at the time was giving
her first talk ever with a power
presentation he actually gave a talk of
black holes in her class it was kind of
cute that myself and my daughter on the
same day gave in a sense a talk about
black holes and me at CERN my daughter
in high school that was kind of a fun
coincidence was not said that was really
a pure coincidence that it's happened on
the same day I I found that kind of
interesting and funny
anyway
um let's call it the day so
in this talk we had a look at a pretty
simple question I mean simple
not
judge from its solution but simple from
the from the outset from the from the
motivation of the problem we we asked
the question what happens
to the second complexity so the number
of gates you need to capture a unitary
four random circuits in
as a function of the depth of the
quantum cycle because Robin suskin have
projected that this should go linearly
in the second depth it's not easy to
decide because well it's computational
problem to compute this complexity but
we found that if you have a random
Quantum circuit the shortest description
so to say will also grow linearly with
the size of a sphere there's no hardly
any redundancy you can compress a bit
but not so much it will still grow
linearly with the size there's only a
bit of
um of uh undoing of of of of of of of of
um going back happens along the way so
there's a linear growth of the
complexity as a function of the second
type that's a fair resolution of this
bronzer skin conjecture we were like
very happy
secretly also because of the methods
coming in of the semi algebraic geometry
it's kind of an acute new portfolio of
methods in this context but it's also
nice to see this kind of contract just
settle in a nice and fair fashion that's
it
well it's just more the beginning of a
program than the end I've already
mentioned that maybe the weakest link to
our work of our work is that we would
like to be able to say more about
approximate Notions I don't want to
oversell this is maybe the something we
should work harder on the method as we
have them are
maybe not powerful enough but we're not
so sure about that either but let's see
that would be interesting to say more
about this and this is surely a a a
construction site for further thinking
then we have this tool available that
would be good and it must be done it
should connect this more to the
holographic setting as it's formulated
and see what it means
and Rob Myers had a couple of ideas on
on how one can could read these settings
that would be highly interesting to see
what this now means for the high energy
context where all this this comes from
in a literal reading of this of this
contractor
I've already hinted as a connection to
the news and costs that's kind of how
high energy people usually see this
notion that's great there's something to
be said already I would like to know
more about this
um this has to be established also we
would like to know more about the
connection to entanglement I've already
mentioned this kind of baby step of
a connection of complexity and
entanglement but it would be super nice
to have stronger statements that relate
to say multi-partite
incremental entangling bounds
of a kind that would give rise to
Stronger bounds of this sauce
I've been thinking quite a bit about
this in my early morning hours over the
late last weeks it's not easy but
let's see but it would be nice to see
more of a connection to to entanglement
compared to Notions of of complexity of
a kind
then yes random circuits are proxies for
hamiltoniannamics for
actual Dynamics for Quantum chaos and
again one should say more about this
about this link we've been started from
proxies for Quantum chaos but well at
some point it would be nice to relate
more to the actual Quantum chaos that's
something we should have on the radar
and there's more to be done but I put it
here on the list of open questions that
we should and and must um think about
something we are working on that some
early progress It's like certainly
complexity with measurements where you
do measurements along the way we know
that circuits with and without
measurements are very different for
example we know that linear depth
circuits are
not very powerful without no
measurements but for example you can't
prepare topological States you can't
prepare GSG that's it so but if you add
measurements you can
um so what's happening to the complexity
goes with measurements there's some
results that see how it goes but that's
really an interesting question
there's connections to kind of air
Corrections or deep F circuits have to
be two Quantum advantages this is
something I I mentioned at the very
beginning that also relates to Scott's
work so we know that if circuits are not
deep enough then we can't come up with
an argument that um kind of that it's
hard to sample from a distribution
classically efficiently that's
sufficiently closed in a precise sense
to the output distribution of the random
circuit followed by measurements but
like at what point you have a kind of
transition and how does the notice of
complexity relate to
computational tasks and computational
tasks in random sampling schemes and
Quantum advantages this should be
fleshed out in in more detail and slowly
um something on the agenda for future
work
and um
nine o'clock on my side that's kind of
purely one hour beyond that time so I
think that's a perfect moment to stop so
I think with this
um I would like to thank you very much
for your precious attention
and I'm very much looking forward to
questions you might possibly
thanks so much
for your attention
great um thanks again that's a really
nice talk
um I think there are there are a number
of questions and if anybody else wants
to you know there are some questions in
the Q a but they're also uh if people
have questions please raise your hands
or if you're in the panel you can you
can also
um try to ask in the meantime just to
just to start it off let me let me just
ask you uh sorry is is there also a
first law of complexity
um that is an interesting question
um
um
so it would be like a
ha well I mean I I wouldn't quite know
what it would be like what's what's what
is it that's um that's being preserved
in in his first
um
the second law makes really sin I mean
it's really like a it's a in a way
almost the same thing of things being I
mean in in one side you're like uh
constrained in your in your position you
can make a measurement like for the
macroscopics
upsell would see like if you make a call
screen measure you would see things
seemingly having more entropy and also
very much related things become more
complex over time because you never go
back that it's very much of a similar
notion but the first law I don't know um
I I would have to think about this
because I wouldn't even know about the
analog of of like what's what is it
that's that's concept
and I wouldn't know whether zeros will
know is for that matter or just maybe
the existence of a complexity of a kind
but uh that's
um I don't know but that's a good
question so so maybe can I can I can I
come at it in a different way it's again
a naive question but um how important
you know how uh you know so so how easy
is it to so if you're if you're making a
bacteria a kind of thermodynamics of
complexity
um how much does the Second Law the the
significance of the second Lord rest on
the first law so how easy is it to skip
over the first law while while
you know is what I'm is is what I'm
trying to understand uh
um
there are different notes
yeah I mean I mean you you need the
zeroth law of thermodynamics right so to
talk about things and you need
um I mean the the second law is kind of
is kind of in primary thermodynamics
it's kind of set up by the
um by the notion of an integrating
factor to have a certain depression
reform
um you
it's largely independent of the first
law
yeah so you don't need the first law for
the second law
so in this sense um there's not a
logical contradiction of not having a
first law why is stating a second law in
a way that's a little bit a bit anyway
yeah yeah
for the two of you sorry good job yeah
so so wouldn't you say first of all the
third law or uh uh you know the the law
that says oh what's the uh I mean did
you did you say that you rest in the
zeroth or third law is that what you
said earlier
however
yeah what is the zeroth law
oh it's just the existence of a family
the existence of a phonological
temperature in phonological uh
thermodynamics so it's like that that
would be like yeah an existence
statement that that would be yeah would
be interesting what's what's the the
Third Law of complexity
um
in thermodynamics the third law is not
true it says that the ground state has
zero degeneracy and has a and and uh
that's not true for many systems but but
you know for the first law you need an
analog of a notion of cost and so you
could imagine a notion yeah but what is
the cost what's the cost yeah well you
know uh certainly for real circuits
there's a cost right they use power they
use this stuff the other so you know you
could wonder if that has a bearing on on
foreignergy and it's particularly pricey
these days and then this is the first
law of complexity because that's the
price Bill to be paid yeah
I don't know
it seems a little a little bit
unsatisfying to me because you know to
me the first law is about conservation
right of some quantity and so what's the
quantity being conserved here but maybe
something to say I mean can we back up a
little bit and ask like in what sense is
there even a second law of complexity uh
because you know I mean certainly there
are particular cases where it is true
that circuit complexity increases with
time you know and and uh Jen's talk
provided a beautiful example right when
you have a Quantum system a pure State
you know subject to a random sequence of
independent Gates then complexity
increases for exponential time okay
there are many other natural situations
where complexity can stay the same or
can decrease over time right uh so you
know uh Sean Carroll and I you know a
decade ago were you know thinking about
how like you know as uh uh you know um
after the big bang you know you get
condensation into you know stars and
galaxies and it seems like most natural
measures of the complexity of you know
the resulting State have gone up but
then in the end there is the heat death
of the universe when we'll all be back
in you know uh uh
um you know some some uh High you know
the entropy will have continued to
increase so we'll be in a very high
entropy state but in some sense it will
be a very low complexity State you know
at least at least uh in the classical
setting at least in our branch of the
wave function right so you know there
are cases there are many situations
where like the second law of
Thermodynamics is true and a second law
of complexity is simply not true right
complexity can first increase and then
decrease so like what is the uh uh realm
of of applicability of the claim second
law of complexity
yeah this is a wonderful point I mean I
I couldn't agree more because I mean in
in the sense the second half is more set
in stone than the second law of of
complexity and I mean there are ways in
which one can make sense of the
um like second law of complexity in in a
kind of quantifiable way in our paper on
uncomplexity on this resource Theory we
even comment on this like we we look at
like fuzzy operations that are like
certain circuits that are have a little
bit of added noise to them and we have
like certain uh um uh like monotones for
which like the complexes like entropy or
so for which one control that they
indeed increase
monotonously with the with the
um with the depth on the fuzzy
operations
which kind of does a baby step in a good
direction but it's maybe not the full
picture because there's fuzzy operations
where the kind of the randomness of the
setting is kind of in in some sense put
in by hand is is actually the call in
the in the in the in the audience you
might even be why being a
a a cause on this like even disagree on
with this picture but but so there's
some senses in which one can formulate
this precisely but I I see your point
that there could be settings where you
get a very complex state but at some
point it gets uncomplexed again and you
come you come back to a low complex
cities point and this might well happen
so I think it's not fully clear I think
I tend to agree what this fully General
second law of complexity should be
if you really want to see it formulated
as a theorem as a quantifiable theorem
and again yeah I showed something but
it's a simple sentence or not even as a
theorem but even just as a statement
that empirically is true across a wide
range of situations I just want to know
what are those situations where we're
claiming that it's empirically true
yeah
um even the statistical mechanics uh in
a bounded system eventually you get poor
query recurrences so you come back so
after you go back down so so these are
really statements about course grading
and certain amounts of ranges of time
recurrences that would also be true for
the second law of thermodynamics
of course obviously everybody but
there's of course two recurrences right
um there's the pokery recurrence that
happens at um at the time that's like
doubly exponential in the system size
that would be idiotically launched for
even tiny systems but there's also like
this um like the province type recurrent
that you often see even in Labs where
all that matters you have a local
excitation that propagates with the
system and it sees the boundary
conditions it comes back and when the
leap Robertson Cohen sees itself you can
see a recurrence and that is kind of
happening at at Early times and when the
second law is like seemingly violated
and so on that happens very early on so
that's of course
sorry can we um you know since we have
already sort of I mean on the channel
maybe we can have the videos pinned for
the panelists and in the meantime
there's there's one question from the
audience so let me allow Jake
because I need to to ask his question
hi um
I thank you very much for the talk it
was very uh very interesting extremely
interesting
um
I was wondering if the contraction maps
that you define there are those actually
projections or or polynomial Maps
oh they are polynomial Maps
so they're basically just I mean they're
just the kind of the realization of the
unitaries in in in in in in a second
they're polynomial maps that map and
architecture to a unitary
okay because as far as I remember the
uh tarsky sunberg uh theorem is for
projections is there a reference that
says uh is true also for polynomials
to be fair it is actually a polynomial
projection because you would get um uh
uh you you get it it's the map from like
input is the architecture like the
placement of the circuits and then you
get U of A as the set of units that you
get given the unitaries of the uh of the
the r unitary Gates that that you put in
yeah okay okay awesome thanks great so
so well we've already sort of
unofficially started the panel but um
Let me let me just introduce the
panelists anyway well the first one uh
you know Scott doesn't need an
introduction here he's been on many
times but he's particularly it's
particularly appropriate he's on this
panel because
um because of course he you know uh of
his interest in all aspects of this from
complexity Theory to uh random Quantum
circuits to uh to these connections with
gravity so uh so maybe Scott after
introducing the last arrest I'll I'll
give you the first short at uh
commenting on on the talk and bringing
up what you what you want to say
um there's nikonda Jones from Stanford
who
you know who's worked extensively on
information scrambling he's he's a he's
really one of the experts on T designs
and Stanford now now UT Austin oh sorry
I said now UT Austin is it no no I mean
yeah there's some transition happening
over the next two months so
mid-transition in in a superposition
between Stanford and UT Austin yet to be
measured and uh and then uh you know
there's uh uh balasubramanian uh from uh
from uh upen who uh who is
um uh who is a theoretical physicist
um uh who is um interested not just in
aspects of uh
um of uh you know the quantum
information information Paradox in in
black holes but also he he has many
sides to him he's a biophysicist
pursuing questions and Neuroscience and
he's he has work uh thought about
machine learning and statistical
inference so uh really great to have you
on the panel video and so Scott can I
Turn to You for for your comments sure
yeah so so so so so thank you Jens for a
really nice talk I mean I was a big fan
of this result when I uh uh saw it come
out but uh I have to uh confess
something right you know you talked
about solving the brown and suskin
conjecture now you know when I heard
Brown and suskin start talking about
this stuff back in 2014 or so you know I
had a complete a very different
understanding of what their conjecture
even was then uh
um so uh so so it seems like there you
know maybe there there are two different
Brown suskin conjectures and you know
and I think the difference between them
is maybe relevant for people since uh uh
it's used for them to understand so so
so so so the so the version that that I
had understood was about a time
independent hamiltonian right so you
know imagine like the same thing keeps
happening to your state over and over
again right uh uh you know so like you
have some H and then you just get could
get like you know PSI zero as your
initial State and you get e to the minus
iht yeah zero where T just becomes
larger and larger you know eventually
exponential and the question was you
know know does this
cause the circuit complexity of the
resulting state to increase linearly
with with take for an exponential time
now the version that you talked about
was the uh a version we could say with a
Time dependent hamiltonian right or you
know if we want to think about it in
discrete language you know my version
would be the the same sequence of gates
is applied over and over your version is
you know a new independent set of random
gates at every time step okay now these
these two versions are really like
crucially different in terms of what we
can expect to prove about them using the
tools that you know that exist today
right with the the the time independent
version the version with the you know
the same hamiltonian that goes on and on
and on right we could you know like what
one thing that I you know just realized
immediately was that if P were equal to
P space for example so if there was some
big collapse of you know conventional
complexity classes then the conjecture
of you know linear growth of circuit
complexity for exponential time would
simply be false right it would just have
no hope of being true because you know a
a uh in polynomial space you could just
go and explicitly calculate what are all
of the amplitudes that you want you know
uh and then you know you could you could
just if P were equal to P space it would
mean you could just go and prepare the
final State using a polynomial size
circuit so therefore any you know and of
course I pointed this out to suskind at
the time and he said okay so then go
make whatever conjectures you computer
science people like to make and then and
then can you prove that this statement
is true and I said okay now we're
talking all right and so then you know I
I did manage to prove
um
some kind of you know complexity growth
for over an exponential amount of time
under uh the assumption that uh P space
is not contained in PP slash poly right
so there's some you know reasonable
looking complexity conjecture where if
it's true then you can say you know and
if furthermore you have a time
independent hamiltonian that
um um uh you know has has the right
properties right it's not not every
hamiltonian that will do this I mean you
know the zero hamiltonian will never
create any complexity right and so I
remember at the time Lenny and uh and
maldicina and others you know had said
well maybe the the relevant property is
some kind of chaos some kind of you know
chaotic behavior of the hamiltonian uh I
was not able to formalize that but I was
able to take a related idea which is you
know computational universality right if
your uh uh hamiltonian is able to sort
of Implement one step of a piece based
computation let's say you know as would
be the case for many River even just
classical reversible cellular automata
or things of that kind then we can sort
of encode in a piece-based computation
in such a way that you know after
exponential time we should get a state
with exponential complexity you know
unless unless there is this collapse of
complexity classes uh now um I was
unable to confirm Lenny's conjecture
that the complexity will increase
linearly you know at most under some you
know under the strongest kind of uh well
understood hypothesis I could say that
you know after tea time the circuit
complexity will be at most T to some
constant power you know T to some you
know I don't know the 1 100th power or
something you know and that was not good
enough for him said no I wanted to to be
linear I said okay well it probably is
linear but you know you've just got to
stick your neck out now and just you
know conjecture that I can't but you
know uh back it up via a a a a a a a a a
a a reduction okay now uh uh what what
you did what you and Nicole and the
others did in this beautiful recent work
was you know to you know use you know
from my point of view use you know the
the very venerable and and an excellent
strategy of of solving a research
Problem by changing the problem okay uh
so you know which you know I mean I mean
you know I I don't you know far from
meaning this as a criticism I was like
you know kicking myself like why didn't
I think of changing the problem in that
particular way right you know you looked
at you know uh okay well what if the you
know you had a different set of gates at
every time step right and then you know
you think you know intuitively it should
be you know all the clearer that
complexity should should just increase
linearly with time but now you know
unlike in in the case that I studied
there there is a hope to just prove it
completely unconditionally right and the
reason is that now you're in the realm
where you can hope to apply some sort of
counting argument right or you know not
you know maybe maybe less accounting
argument than a dimension argument right
you know now you can bring algebraic
geometry to Bear you know as you
explained in the talk and you can say
well as you get to higher and higher
depths you're generating a higher and
higher dimensional
um with a semi-algebraic set right and
you know you just if you have a smaller
circuit I just don't have enough
Dimensions to sort of cover all of the
stuff that I am you know thereby
creating okay so that so that was uh
um
you know a beautiful thing to to
actually you know formalize and prove
right it's like you know once you know
um you know I like like it it's one of
these things where like like you know
yeah um yes you know what what once it
once it's once it's done it's like you
know it's like uh people are like oh
well you know I I I I I I I I should
have realized that that Cannon should be
done okay so uh yeah
uh I did have one um maybe little
technical question for you
um
um um you know so you talked about how a
constant number of t-gates suffice for
uh for for tea designs okay so so I
don't know if you're aware there's a
brand new paper by a group of students
uh here at UT Austin uh Sabi Grewal
Vishnu hi or William kratzmer and Daniel
Liang
um which shows that a a constant number
of t-gades does not suffice for
producing a pseudo-random Quantum state
so in other words if you want a state
that will look like a har random state
with respect to you know whatever
polynomial time measurement you you
could apply then they show that you need
at least
um order login P Gates okay and they
give they do this by giving an explicit
algorithm that can actually distinguish
a state you know with a small number of
key Gates or with a small enough uh
stabilizer extent or some measure like
that from a truly random Quantum State
um so so so uh here here here is the
paper uh so my question was about you
know how do we reconcile that with your
claim that a constant number of T Gates
suffice or they just are they just two
different questions
oh okay wonderful so thanks a lot that
was
interesting what you said it's like
basically a talk in its own right so so
I'm the panelist and you're the the
speaker and I'm also a beautiful welcome
and then in the past like relates this
question to notice of complexity
um it's also I mean I I see this like as
an argument how um inspiring Lenny is in
a way because that's we had I have this
question that you mentioned on the radio
in fact I when I mentioned on my last
slide we would have the connection to
the true Quantum chaos I actually meant
the hamiltonian version so the time uh
independent version which I read as a
variant of the original problem so I I
saw the two problems exactly the other
way around
when you think about this
um so I know this variant and I saw this
as about it never mind these are both
interesting questions
um
and um I I I know the question so
there's of course this was a big
literature in in in in random Quantum
circuits and what properties they have
and so on in all the readings from the
mathematical side but all going all the
way to condensed matter and and to
Identity so in this in this lingual
people discriminate a discriminate like
Brownian circuits from Pro case circuits
like the brownie would be what we have
like take a new hard random guy every
every time and look at a deep circuit
where's the fluke key thing would be
like a b a b a b a b a b type where you
one straw Randomness and then you do the
same thing over and over again and right
that's what you said basically you have
a fixed random magnetonian and then you
authorize it maybe and then you get
something there's some Randomness but
you fix it once and for all and it's
been repeated over time and I agree it
is very natural and then when I
complained that I would like to know
more about this at the very end I meant
your reading of the bronzuscan
conjecture
well I'm losing control over the
conjecture space besides the second law
of complex is also bronzer skin
conjecture so it's more like a portfolio
of Franciscan projectors never mind I
know this problem and we are thinking
about this but it's not easy um yeah uh
also in a way because you don't have
enough Randomness available
um right so counting arguments we seem
to say this yourself are not so easy
because
um it's a kind of interplay of the
hamiltonian Dynamics and the randomness
you have initially that brings you
always to a new realm but having new
renders available in each step makes
this step much easier whereas if you're
repeating with the same thing that
presumably it's the same thing happening
mathematically speaking but it's very
difficult to capture so no they require
so yes I think in a new student who
thinks deeply about this he got a bit
distracted by the new doing work on
measurements and he's making progress
but that's a secret
like like other Pathway to overcome the
hardness of the problems that you you
sketched so I'm much aware of the
problem I would have loved to solve it
but um or contribute in one way or the
other doing that
um yeah it is what it is ah then ah
computational University of course I
mean our circuits are computationally
Universal because they are random and
that set up also I mean the the notion
of exact complexity would be really
awkward if you have not a universal
Gator that's kind of funny but this is
of course the case on on your last point
on the on the um on the um
on the designs this is not a
contradiction because it really matters
on the fine print of approximation so
um there's a relationship or a nickname
can truly command on this um being a
design expert there's a very clear
notion between a unitary design on the
one hand like designs in the unity group
and spherical designs like complex
spherical designs which are the same
thing on on the state Vector level in
fact take a fit crucial State and then
you apply in their design you get uh
automatically a spherical design
but the fine print matters and um so the
sense of approximation method so if you
have a weaker sense of or different
sense of approximation we also get the
locked n dependence so the way we set it
up is a fair way of thinking of an
approximate design in a way and then we
get this end Independence which is like
striking but
um if you made use of the right sense of
approximation that would relate this
notion to the appropriate notion on the
level of spherical designs I thought I
would think there's no contradiction and
there would be we would get the log
Independence as they have them that's
what I would think
um Nick can you confirm this uh yeah I
mean I I haven't read this most recent
paper but I expect it to get the
statement that you know some design
implies this notion of computational
pseudor Randomness you probably need to
take some strong notion of design which
requires taking some approximation error
to be exponentially small and just as
you pointed out that gives you some
Independence on the number of t-gates
you need to get designs so presumably to
get one to to imply the other the the
lack of contradiction is going to be
resolved by the fact that you need to
take a certain approximation which will
make the results agree exactly yeah okay
and maybe maybe one other point yeah I
think this is also that's a good point
it's very observed so yeah that's nice
okay thank you so it's also not
something I know for for complexities so
to prove to prove that um or I guess the
way we know how to relate like
complexity and and unitary designs uh uh
you know also requires I mean we use
approximate designs and there's a very
specific step where you bound you
basically want to bound the probability
that some fixed unitary is far away from
like a design element uh yeah
this kind of hypothesis testing
framework and and to do this you use
markov's inequality and you balance sort
of moments moments of traces of these
unitaries and and I guess the way we use
designs in that step requires taking
like the additive error to be
exponentially small
um so and this is fine if you have like
1D circuits because you have some log
one over Epsilon and you could take that
exponentially small it just gives you
some factor that you don't care about
basically
um but for for for these uh homeopathic
circuits like this would necessarily
mean that the number of t-gates you need
is like system size dependent but this
could also just be like I don't know you
know this is just some step in a proof
where it's convenient to take this uh
additive error to be a relative error
and uh I have no idea if like uh if
that's actually necessary so I think
it's you know I think if you want to get
the same steps of the proof to work for
these Clifford circuits with t Gates uh
for complexity you do need like a system
size dependent number of T Gates but
that could also just be like a poor step
in the proof which you could optimize
and and maybe these homeopathic circuits
with uh like a very few content system
size independent number of T Gates
actually do give you uh the complexity
growth oh yeah wonderful ideas wonderful
Point yeah I could agree more with
everything you say I think also that
resolves we agree already on on the
resolution of this yeah I always agree
on the on the on the on the notion of
approximation that you need to make the
connection between designs and and
complexity that's right I mean that's
also I I I've cited your work and I
should stress the beautiful work that
also Nick has done together with paranda
and so on and others on on this book on
this on this um um on this question and
yes I I I mean clearly there's a
dependence on the on the system size in
the number of tickets you need but this
could be a flaw of the proof I mean how
do we know it as you say I I agree yeah
I mean I speak this in a bit actually to
be I even said this that the sort of I I
call it procrastination I couldn't just
resist on saying this because I kind of
I find it funny that any meaningful
notion of approximation that is he kind
of traded on the mark it would have that
feature which I find really quite quite
striking but um of course not it there's
more to be said on the question yes yeah
I mean if they should truly deserve the
name of homeopathic circuits then the
fewer the t-gates you have you know the
better the mixing property should be
yeah that's right
that that at least then we failed so
it's not quite homeopathic it'd be
awesome
that it came too much with a with a um
with the email requests of us doing that
Quantum healing and saving the world
do you have any uh sure yeah so first of
all beautiful talk and I love the paper
uh but I do concur that I don't think
this little branches can conjecture so
the brown testing is about physical
systems in which there is a hamiltonian
and the idea is you can phrase it in
various variants of it either in the
holographic context there's some notion
that there is some notion of complexity
of the growth of the some some notion of
complexity associated with the time
development of a fixed Quantum system
okay it was somehow related to uh let's
say volume or something in the space now
there are many problems there one is uh
of course if one thing is increasing
monotonically in time another thing is
increasing one atomically in time for a
long time you know just because they're
both increasing monotonically doesn't
mean they're equal right
anatomically in time so this is the
proof required there of a relationship
so that's been completely missing and
that's of course one of the goals that
one would have in the field but secondly
secondly in terms of the complexity
growth you know so really the question
there is if I give you a fixed
hamiltonian right there are some
theories that are in some sense simple
like integrable theories where the
entire Dynamics may be controlled by
three numbers the integration constants
of the theory from which you can specify
put into the Dynamics whereas chaotic
Dynamics where that's not going to be
the case now in classical chaos there's
actually different degrees of chaos so
there are systems like the kicked rotor
where in some regime of parameters
you'll find that it's not chaotic
anywhere then you tweak it and then for
some other parameter it's chaotic in
some regions of its face space but not
others and then some other region of the
Paramus is chaotic everywhere and
actually in the study of quantum chaos
it's not understood how that happens so
there are sort of deep and important
questions about the nature of chaos and
quantum mechanics but this has a bearing
on but these questions have a bearing on
you might you know you'd readily imagine
that there is a uh a sort of a a sort of
refined version of the conjecture which
says that you know as you go as you
increase the degree of chaos whatever
that means in the hamiltonian in the
fixed hamiltonian the rate of complexity
growth or the Persistence of complexity
growth you know how long it stays for
you know changes or something like that
right so so that maximally chaotic
theories whatever that precisely means
have you know exponential growth for a
long period of time so I think from the
physics point of view those are the
statements that are most interesting
however however
you know how uh you know going back to
the work of Eugene wigner one of the
things one the conjecture of Eugene
wigner many many decades ago was that if
you take a sufficiently complicated
hamiltonian like the one that controls
nuclear uh nuclei so Nuclear Physics or
sufficiently uh complicated systems like
that then the conjecture uh due to
wigner was that the spectrum of the
hamiltonian will be well approximated by
that of a random Matrix that doesn't
mean that if I give you a particular
Theory like the theory of iron that it
is exactly the results of random Matrix
but that certain Universal features of
the spectrum will be controlled by
random Matrix so I personally think that
these kinds of random circuits that are
so beautifully being discussed both in
your work and elsewhere
May well be turn out to be capturing the
universal features of you of you know of
maximally chaotic Dynamics because it
could be that a very chaotic system the
system changes and then it sort of
reconfigured itself in such a
complicated way but the next step is in
some effective sense essentially random
compared to the previous step so that
kind of thing could be very powerfully I
think used so so I think these results
that you're talking about are very
important because they may well turn out
to be the universal part or whatever
answer you want to give for your
strongly coupled many body interacting
systems I think that I think that's the
way in which I you know I personally
think of what I've learned but one can
make progress for the actual thing too
so for example in our work uh you know
we just decided just take seriously you
want to take hamiltonians actual
hamiltonians that are chaotic or
integrable and try to see how that
complexity grows and as you're
mentioning you know we tend to uh in
physics we often tend to take this
Nielsen point of view because it sort of
feels natural for people who like
continuous math right so the idea there
uh just to recall is that the complexity
of so well anyway time development is a
trajectory of the unitary group and so
you want to find the shortest path in
the appropriate complexity metric from
the identity to uh you know the to the
time Evolution operator and so you're
supposed to find this as far as path so
that's a Judicial problem for which
we've actually made a lot of progress so
you can solve that problem to some
extent and um you can show that
universally uh in fact the initial
growth of the geodesic link is linear so
there's this initial linear growth
really the question is does it truncate
and there are two modes in which you can
track it and do kind of shortcuts that
could appear one involves you have this
manifold uh you know the unitary group
is some strange fiber bundle complicated
fiber bubble so one class of
obstructions are the global obstructions
that is you know you come back around
the other side and that's the shortcut
you've been going this way with a
hamiltonian and you come back around
that side so finding such Global
obstructions is a hard problem in
topology and geometry however there's
another very interesting class of
obstructions called conjugate points
which are uh sometimes when they
accumulate they indicate the presence of
some sort of global obstruction but
actually these are local obstructions
this complexity growth so it turns out
that you can directly give criteria
related things like spectral properties
properties in the eigen states of a
system things that look like the
eigenstate thermalization hypothesis
Criterion you can you can write down a
number of criteria that are familiar in
physics involving spectral properties of
a theory that tell you
um that bound when these local
obstructions are going to happen so you
can show for example that um and so this
is what some of the stuff that we showed
that if you take sort of an integrable
theories at polynomial time you begin to
see these obstructions appearing right
these local conjugate points so you know
that complexity growth terminates a
linear complexity growth terminates at
most a polynomial time in some of these
integrable theories good they're not
maximally chaotic so we didn't expect
exponential growth another thing you can
show by using the same criteria that is
if you take uh say for example chaotic
examples of this syk model you know
other kinds of models like that you can
show that at exponential time these
local obstructions the complexity growth
do occur in other words it's not the
case that because that that you can keep
growing in complexity past exponential
time it will truncate in this particular
way so I think these are very
interesting and they connect directly to
properties of dynamics of chaotic and
integrable systems so I think this is an
interesting Avenue that you know we were
interested in in following and that
connects to some of the other things you
said you know if you're going to connect
to things in holography you want to talk
about the specific kind of and physical
systems that have a relationship with
logically random circuits don't
but it would be so cool to show that if
I give you any one of these maximally
chaotic theories that there is something
Universal in their dynamics that is in
fact captured by random circuits perhaps
because the state changes so much from
step to step but the effect of evolution
in some appropriate sense is random so I
also want to raise that you know we're
here very much talking in the circuit
complexity kind of language and your
nuisance methods of course were designed
as a way of you know giving some
continuous math version of estimating
things like the circuit complexity but
the other Notions you could invent so
for example imagine you say that a
system the time evolution in a Quantum
system is complicated if the wave
function spreads in some sense
um uh uh well the complexity of the
evolution is related to the spread of
the wave function over the Hilbert space
now what does that mean at any given
time of course you can pick your basis
Vector to be that state so it feels like
it isn't spreading but you could say
that you want to create a basis so that
you can describe all uh you know all uh
all the state vectors let's say up to
time t i i i i i don't want to just
describe the state Vector at time T but
I want to have a fixed basis to describe
everything and then you can write down
the basis that minimizes the spread so
because you'd like to sort of uh the
basis in which the spread is asked as as
as slow as possible that that would be a
sensible way of trying to quantify how
rapid the spread is you pick a basis
that is as slow as possible so this
method is going back to the 60s uh due
to a guy named longshos some Hungarian
God and krill oil than others but how to
compute spaces and again you can show
that you can construct integrable models
like particles and group manifolds and
you can see that this thing truncates
quickly and so on so forth that's like
chaotic examples like the kind of uh
Evolution expected in random Matrix
models but you can show that the growth
is linear for an exponential amount of
time and then plateaus so that's another
quantity which I don't know precisely
what I mean it's not entirely clear what
the precise relationship between that
kind of spread notion of complexity and
circuit complexity is presumably well
there may be a relation that will not be
a relation I'm just pointing out that
there's multiple quantities that have
this kind of linear kind of growth and
uh and in that case in the case of the
wave function spread provably so you
just calculate it and you demonstrate
that it exists and and so so going back
to the question of what is the
relationship with the volume growth in
gravity and stuff like that it's not
obvious I think apriori which of these
Notions if any of them is actually has a
holographic duo in the volume and I
think it's very important to keep that
in mind because all people run away and
calculate volumes of gravity and say oh
I've computed complexity
well it's very important here to Define
what you meant by complexity and which
notion was being prepared so I think
that's that's uh but a very exciting
right I mean the reason we do this is
because we don't know the answer to that
question or to many of these questions
so so anyway my two cents thanks thanks
that's great so I mean uh that's like
more like the the program of a of a live
career in science
that you're presenting here I hope
you're not I'm expecting I think we're
gonna make I think we're going to make
progress on this much quicker than a
life career I think I think all the
people in place we should actually
speaking of which we should also catch
up soon on a one-to-one level and and
discuss stuff a bit yeah talk about
um maybe too much for for this evening
but um but there's many many interesting
thoughts so I mean first I noticed that
you seem to be pretending towards the
hamiltonian
type reading of the conjecture anyway I
noticed this I'm great
that is there that is what they write
right I mean they're talking about
physical systems that are changing not
over random circuits yeah I think
technically if you dive into that paper
they do conjecture it for yeah I mean
I'll take the opposing view from BJ and
Scott that if you write something in a
paper and you say you think it's true
it's fair to call it a you know Brown
zustin conjecture so think of you if you
look in their paper they do say oh this
should be true for random circuits so
okay yeah they say both so it's about to
offer I think we've come up with it
they're both interesting and in a way we
say what we can say I mean I say that
the assumptions and that's what we get
so yeah and and and and let me go
through these these these different
points I mean yeah I mean also I'm aware
of your beautiful work and then in that
context maybe
um
on the quantum chaos side yeah as you
must know there's lots of Notions of
quantum chaos like integability I mean
we have five different meanings of
integrability
yeah
um
and they're like being literally
integrable in the sense of uh classical
mechanics and then having like a a
like end linearly independent uh
constant emotion that and algebraically
Depends because there's lots of that
speed integrability there's lots of
different Notions and and chaotic is a
bit similar there's system systems that
are quantum chaotic if the analogous
classical mechanical Hamilton is is
chaotic people talk about open Quantum
systems which are in Facebook chaotic
that people talk about properties of out
of time or correlation functions these
are all related but not identical
properties it's nice but you seem to be
on the right path in the sense that uh
it's much easier to talk about what is
not chaotic than what is chaotic so
that's a very wide step forward so if
you get these funny um actually actually
actually
ends I'm not sure that's the case I'm
starting to get the impression that it's
a sort of bit tolstoyan but every
integrable system is integrable in its
own way but all chaotic systems have
something Universal in them
to hear more about this I mean we
actually I should be honest that I'm way
more
um knowledgeable on north of
integrability I've written like a
hundred Pages review article on then on
notice of chaos I I would be happy to
hear more about your thoughts anyway but
anyway what you said literally and I
agree is that it seems to be easier to
find but not chaotic because if you get
like constraints that you see
um constraining aerodynamics then you
see funny things such as there's a
linear growth of complexity for time but
then it gets stuck because it can't go
further because of that something some
uh something non-chaotic is is coming
that's super interesting and highly
exciting
then ah on the universality
um
I I I couldn't agree more that this is a
super interesting uh research question
on like seeing what the universal part
is and of course I'm aware of the
literature on how random Matrix Theory
captures some properties like Spectra of
hamiltonians but not others I believe
you think about that it's crazy yeah you
random Matrix Theory captures local
Spectra of local many body hamiltonians
and that's just a property of a uniform
running Matrix theory if you think about
that it's a a a a a a matrix that's
completely structureless that captures
the spectrum of a local hamiltonian but
there's one of these are missing it's
not local the locality is completely
ignored and the spectrum is still right
I had a conversation with a with a
condensed method person not long ago
where I was asking about this oh but you
know there's a two by two Matrix wait
there's a locality no no it's the same
oh wait you're right the locality is
missing yeah whoa it's kind of crazy but
um so motivated by this and your lines
of thought we have been thinking a
little bit in that direction and we had
a paper recently that it actually that
really Builds on Nick's beautiful work
on stat make models actually it's a an
add-on to his models where we looked at
say random matrix product states where
we have a matrix product set and you
draw IID random the the the the the the
the the content of the tensors
to prove stuff that you can't prove
otherwise and we do lots of things for
example we can show that these guys put
um show exponentially strong
equilibration properties if you start
from a product under generic
hamiltonians of course everybody
believes this to be true and even a
phenomenal wrote something about this in
1930
or something
um conjecturing this but it can hardly
be proven so we had to prove that for
um if that for for if you look at random
metaphoric States and you look at the
evolution under
um a generic hamiltonian then you would
get exponential equilibration in the
sense that the the variants would be
there's a large variation Bound for the
for the variance that you're mostly get
the the the time average setting why am
I saying this ah because our secret
motivation was very similar to yours
namely that we wanted to kind of average
out the non-universal stuff and see the
the the real thing
so we're playing around playing with um
say random spt like random symmetry
protected topologically all at states
where we have like a a constraint and
the rest is taken random and the
randomness kind of average is average
away and only the the the
topological features remain
and we have a bit of progress on that on
that front
um a paper that was almost done is one
that takes random uh match decay tensors
in an ads in an ads tiling
that's actually quite interesting it's
like one of these toy models of tens of
10 networks for ads CFT models and you
have a kind of negatively curved um uh
space you have a tiling and you place
um
tenses on on the tiling and they are
match gate standards like free fermions
but they are randomly picked
and then we can actually get a Continuum
limit of that and can get an integral
explain a closed form expression of the
state on for the state on the boundary
from a random picture we put we we
joined Force but Alex Outland was like
an expert in this in these integrals
he's a magician and you got to get an
expression for and effectively
interacting theory on the boundary which
is critical and there's a tangent
another picture of that
why am I saying this well I'm cheating
it's not the time dependent version
but it's a setting in which we look at a
random a structure of random times a
setting where we kind of average out the
non-universal stuff and keep the the
universal features so that's more a
little bit in your mindset although not
not quite but um I'm aware of the
questions it's like super interesting we
should do something together about this
uh thanks thanks for the for this so so
um maybe just um coming back briefly to
something that Vijaya said uh you know
you you said something about um
uh that that was uh quite uh evocative
you know you said well there were these
two quantities that increased linearly
you know once the volume of the Wormhole
and the other is complexity and of
course that doesn't mean that they are
yeah you know the fact that there are
many things that might increase linearly
yeah so uh so you know that was um
you know that was the starting point for
for
um the work that Adam buland bill
pfefferman and I did uh you know we were
we were sort of thinking you know come
on you know
just the fact that these are increasing
linearly doesn't mean they are the same
so let's let's actually show that um you
know complexity behaves in different
ways and we started thinking about
pseudorandom Quantum States and said
well you know this would have
implications about about this uh about
this thing and and in fact uh
uh what we ended up showing is not just
you know some some implications of
pseudorandom you know the fact that he
could embed pseudor random States in in
the cfd for the complexity of the of the
dictionary map but we also ended up
showing to our surprise
that in fact whatever was dual to
whatever operator was was dual to volume
in the cfd it had to be something like
computational complexity
how do you show that how do you show uh
uh whatever is dual to well I don't know
how to write down a volume operator in
the field right no but but I would
evaluate it and and try to improve your
conjecture yeah so it was it was a
complexity theoretic argument saying
that uh look because because uh because
we could write down pseudo-random states
that were you know that uh
um that corresponded to the growth of
the Wormhole you know so so in other
words we we said we can embed this sort
of
um uh pseudonym states that that marked
time you know marked the marked the
evolution in the in the CFT
and now
um
uh whatever operator you have that's
that that that that tells you how long
it took you know from looking at this
pseudor random state it must it must be
keeping track of the computational
complexity somehow because because the
pseudor random state
will not you know will not reveal this
information to you in any other way so
so it was it was essentially saying you
know that that uh whatever it is it has
to be you know it it need not be exactly
the the circuit complexity in terms of
the number of age required to do this
but it has to be some close variant of
it it can't be very different so it came
as a major surprise to us and it was yet
another case where where I think
back sorry my computer crashed I'm so
sorry
um
reasonably short but I'm sorry and my
computer crashed I I got it back up
uh the last time I heard that was that
um no no um I I I I I I
got it onto the point when you talked
about your own work on on the on the
volume growth being like seemingly the
same as complexity growth so I'm I'm
sorry yeah yeah so that that's uh so
Vijay was asking how can I can I can I
ask for a clarification of that or
rather let me repeat that make sure I
understood a disappointed that I don't
completely understand so suppose the
states are still around and as might be
natural indeed but thinking about this
for the wormholes are you saying that uh
uh is there an argument that any object
you compute in that state any operator
whose expectation value let's say you're
Computing that state which grows whose
expectation value grows linearly for an
exponential time has to be you know
basically some simple function of
circuit complexity or some notion of
complexity is that so so basically you
know basically they're saying look if
you look at the state itself it looks
random you know it you know so if you
have any any simple operator of it it
really won't reveal to you how you know
the the how long it's been evolving but
the Wormhole has been evolved you know
its volume is proportional to how long
it's been evolving so so now you have
you know it's like you have this you
have this disguise you know the state is
a you know has is uh is disguised in
some ways so that if you look at it from
the outside and you don't penetrate the
disguise then any sort of regular
operator you you you compute okay so I
think I understood I think I understood
I have a question come coming back so I
think what you said is because the state
is pseudorandom if you wanted to
construct an object which would actually
measure that time if you like in
whichever way you want or since the
beginning then that object has to be
very complex in its own right because
you know simple operator would not
distinguish in these things but why does
that so so but so the point I'd like to
get this so that that seems very
reasonable and you know excellent as a
statement
um uh but but my question is why does
that mean then that it computes
complexity of the state
and what does that precisely mean sorry
I mean I'm using the word complexity
here without defining it in three
different ways myself so I'm just hoping
you'd clarify uh what what the precise
statement is there
yeah so so it's um it's just saying look
um
so
um
um so so so what what they're saying is
is
um
you know you you would have thought that
there are there are many other
properties that um you know that you
could you could call on which which
might be growing linearly who knows what
else is is growing linearly and we're
sort of saying you know whatever
property it is it's not going to be an
easy property it's not it's not going to
be something natural and easy to compute
so at that point what are you left with
it's you know it's got to grow linearly
with the amount of time you you know
it's been it's been uh it's been
evolving you know what what else are you
going to choose at that point you know
it's some it's something that has very
high computational complexity it's
something impenetrable you know it may
as well be somewhere in computation so
the I I fully agree that the object that
one will have to compute has very high
computation complexity that seems clear
for the reasons you explained uh and
Adam and and uh and uh and Bill
explained that that it has to uh so I
guess part of the reason I'm sort of
pushing
is because you know the sort of uh the
the sort of tradition I'm used to trying
to do things in the adsc FD is if
there's something on one side it's a
dictionary maybe a CFT correspondence so
I would very much like to State the
dictionary elements so this object on
this side it's this object in this side
so I think your arguments tell us that
the object of this side the CFT has to
be uh you know it's not it's not like
you know write down a little operator
here and there this is some
computationally complex object you've
got to write down
um it still seems to me that there may
be indeed exponentially many objects of
exponentially High complexity and it's
not immediately obvious which one of
those objects I should pick but but hey
one of them is the one uh
can I say something I mean I always view
the complexity equals volume hypothesis
or whatever as you know uh uh uh more of
an aspiration right I mean you know
they're like there's
um you know the first of all there are
different versions even just of circuit
complexity you can allow in silicubits
you cannot allow enzoa qubits right and
you know and there seem to be there
never seem to be any principled way of
choosing you know which circuit
complexity is the one that should be
dual to Value right and so so I always
said okay well you know you want
something on the CFT side you know on
the boundary theory that behaves like an
intrinsic clock that tells you how long
your state has been evolving for right
we can understand why various kinds of
circuit complexity would do that job
right and you know and and and that
seemed like the best stand-in that we
can come up with for whatever
complicated hard to characterized thing
you know actually does do that job right
and now what bfv have added to the
conversation is the further Insight that
like if your objection to Circuit
complexity was the it is too hard to
compute then that objection is now mute
okay because anything any quantity on
the CFT side that's going to do the job
yeah is going to all be similarly hard
to compute right yeah so so but I but I
would still stand by yeah it doesn't
have to be circuit complexity per se in
the particularly
the people have chosen to define it yeah
that could still just be a stand-in for
some other thing exactly exactly you
know it was a sort of an Occam freezer
thing right so for somebody who does
complexity Theory you know we're sort of
saying look
how you know why would you jump to
something so extravagant right away you
know you know computational complexity
is not something we think of as feelable
or something that's that should be an
observable in a physical sense and so
you say any other candidate will have
the same feature being not efficiently
computed but that that brings the the
dream to rest the region of having like
this dictionary actually which I learned
from you in a way you gave the wonderful
talk once in Aspen where you've got but
there was this big confusion about this
dictionary then you were pushed into
giving an impromptu talk on this in the
afternoon and you just had two hours in
the in the lunch break to prepare the
talk and then you were supposed to give
an important or the dictionary between
the CFT side and the gravity side so I
learned much of the dictionary actually
from you from this talk but having said
that
um this kind of brings the dream to rest
that there will be one quantity that
would capture trade but there's just
many other quantities as well that could
be equally nothing
may I push back on that comment um
because I'm going to hold out hope that
there's a quantity so I accept from uh
the original argument and from dfv and
all of these things that whatever object
it is it's computationally complex right
so that doesn't so that means that if I
try to write to death on my piece of
paper it could happen so easily right
but that doesn't mean that there isn't a
specific object and the reason why you'd
hope for one of some kind is because in
these correspondences you know the
volume is the volume you know there's a
number there and there's some object
that's supposed to track this number so
out of the many different
computationally confidence version would
be one of them has an expectation value
that tracks this and that's the volume
operator so you know traditionally in
things like the quantum theory of
gravity people used to try to write down
stuff like the volume operator right
it's very interesting right that's a
there's this emergent space in which
there's a thing that you wind up calling
volume and you know in the in the cfd
there is no volume there's no such thing
right so it's going to have a question
to you then I have a question to you
which is I mean you must be aware of all
these kind of very concrete like tensor
Network models of adsft that captures
some of the real thing and I mean in
some way you can even get a CFT out that
maybe is a CFT up to like some quality
periodic structure or something like
what would these um toy models for the
sft with a
where the volume goes what would they
say about this question yeah so so yeah
in this case I think you're asking the
wrong person because I don't think
actually myself I don't think the
transistor Network models capture those
aspects of okay
for for a specific reason for a specific
reason for a specific reason so there's
a sense in which what tensor networks do
is let's suppose that these in these
cases you know the the ads space has a
scale right the scale is the ads skill
and the ads scale could be you know a
500 light years huge huge right so when
you write down the tensor Network
description of these spaces each node in
the tensor network is supposed to
represent One ads volume right a size it
can be enormous so there's large parts
of what we would conventionally call the
volume of the space that are not
included on the other hand I think yes I
think you're what you're asking is it's
a totally meaningful question that you
could say how many of these nodes are
there right you could take each of these
nodes in the tensor networks yeah
yeah so so okay so I would draw
particularly what I said and say uh and
I haven't thought about it carefully
enough yeah
three paper ideas already on the desk
tonight that's good
well great uh well thanks a lot
everybody thanks Jens for a great uh
very stimulating talk and uh
also a very you know a really
stimulating discussion
so yeah I enjoyed it a lot it was
wonderful thanks guys that was really
absolutely great thank you
yes yes we have to talk about
compressive sensing yeah no no no it's
not my my to-do list let's do this soon
that's right yeah
bye guys
foreign